my name is Rob rang and i'm a senior
director and head of Pfizer's autism
research unit which is based in Groton
Connecticut what role do you see public
private partnerships playing in
advancing the field of therapeutic
development in autism research well I
could try and is that because we're very
involved in that at the Simons
Foundation at last year we spent 60
million dollars to try and enhance
research relevant to autism and we are
now looking for partnerships because no
one can do this on their own no matter
how dedicated or how many resources they
have so they need to be partnerships
with industry and with the NIH I think
we also need more cooperation and
collaboration between the school system
and the universities that are doing
research in many areas it's very very
hard to get into the public school
system for example for universities to
do research there and I think that that
creates a major problem and the main
problem is that our research findings
aren't getting out into the community
they're not getting to the medical
community they're not getting into the
just the general practice why is that
right I don't know certainly in Los
Angeles there are major bureaucracies
and unions associated with how the
schools work and they do not want
outside influence i think that there's a
perception that if we come up with a
treatment that is effective that they
will be mandated to to deliver that that
intervention and they don't have the
finances to do that I think that we have
a general problem in that we haven't
quite figured out if autism is something
that should be treated in the medical
world or in the educational world and
each of course would like to put it in
the other place so that they won't have
to pay for it and there isn't really a
unified approach to dealing with that
one of course it needs to be dealt with
in both worlds and so there's a lot of
passing the buck and no clear way of
facilitating getting research and
getting new treatments into the places
where it needs to be that's fascinating
I think in the medical arena there's
also a lot of room for improvement 20 or
30 years ago came the rise of the
Comprehensive Cancer Center because
there was the availability of new cancer
chemotherapeutic agents that had to be
tested and that showed promise as
recently as two or three years ago
nobody thought that we needed that for
autism because there was no reason to
think that any specific agents would be
useful and that's what's changing and as
dr. Fishbach mentioned we need to now
start using cancer as a model where we
get a much higher proportion of kids and
families with autism enrolled and
involved in the opportunity to try out
new medical agents but that will require
a major partnership to realign how we
really think of the condition it's it
really is a multi-faceted problem with
lots of potential and the simons
foundation is funding mostly research
but physicians are not compensated very
well for taking care of people with
autism so there's got to be greater
government awareness even beyond the
usual withdrawal from mental health
problems lack of support you know people
think it's your fault you should pay for
it but compensation for physicians and
hospitals for the care of people with
autism perhaps leading to clinical
trials and long-term observation these
trajectories really has to depend on a
government private facility partnership
I know several places that are trying
this but everyone is risk averse and
worried about the finances of it